alright the Backstreet Boys are back on
stage with the show in Las Vegas the
band has sold 130 million records
worldwide since its start in the 1990s
vladimir duthiers of our streaming
network cbsn caught up with the band at
Planet Hollywood Hotel and Casino just
minutes away from takeoff backstage with
the Backstreet Boys we're three nights a
week
time to get buckled in they arrive in
five floating screens
[Applause]
people can't you see can't you see
see all the hits from the past or 20 to
22 weeks right
yes helping our fans reel it relive some
of their the history with us AJ you guys
your moves are still sharp as ever but
you've all we've all gotten a little
older teacher does performing the moves
make you feel your age or does it take
it back to being a kid me personally
I've had two knee surgeries
Kevin had knee surgery one of the many
things I think that has helped us kind
of stand the test of time is that we are
performers we're a bunch of hams
we're going to keep dancing until we
literally need walkers and/or like
wheelchairs and we just can't do it
anymore the Backstreet Boys first got
together in Orlando Florida back in 1993
Kevin was the oldest at 21 Nick was just
13 but I just remember how hard it was
being in a warehouse where all these
blimp parts were stored there was no air
conditioning there we didn't get the
lottery ticket we got a chance to have a
lottery ticket and we worked really hard
to make that dream come true
[Music]
- I don't think I
their music was slow to catch on it was
the early 90s grunge overshadowed pop
music so the boys went to Europe and the
girls went crazy quit playing games with
mine
[Music]
in 1997 quit playing games became their
first hit in America they climbed to
number two on the charts and ignited
backstreet fever
[Applause]
[Music]
those girls who want screamed and
dreamed of a close encounter are now
grown up and showing up in Vegas
[Applause]
their show is selling out
[Music]
and the world's best-selling boyband is
now better equipped to handle the
trappings of too much too soon
in 2001 after nearly eight years of
constant touring AJ McClain revealed he
was addicted to drugs and alcohol
through the years McClain has been in
and out of rehab several times I'm sober
today that's all I can say it will
always be a constant struggle no matter
what and I have an awesome support team
with my wife and my family with my work
family
[Applause]
[Music]
I do hope and I do think at some point I
will string together in many many years
but it matches me being completely
honest and Brian Littrell is opening up
about his struggle with muscle tension
dysphonia triggered partly by stress it
causes the muscles around the voice box
to constrict impairing his vocal range
Luttrell tried to hide his condition
from the group what about vocals on aims
are we gonna talk about that even here
in Jennifer knows only one as good as
you used to
he secretly entered therapy my voice is
you know it's my body the guys learned
about it two years ago when Latrell
shared his problem with a documentary
film crew it's frustrating it's very
frustrating because I wanna you know I
just want to be me do you watch this
movie together and a whole bunch of
stuff came out that you didn't eat oh
yeah we were sitting there crying at a
theater just just affected it only
started to happen as you got older it's
been happening for like six years I want
to say and if I had gotten it earlier
you know I might be doing better today
but I think I'm onward and upward I'm
I'm moving moving forward she's not
afraid of you anymore
what were you the way that you guys were
going at each other is the way that real
family members actually fight it's true
I mean we've had we've had more fights
than that over the years but physically
that we're never publicized I mean I've
had the most difficult fight and
recently we I mean we are a family yeah
and their family has grown they're all
married with eight kids between them and
no surprise the Backstreet babies are
growing into fans my oldest is a total
performer just like her dad
and has a big big crush on this way
every time she asks daddy did you guys
do this today did you suck right move
and where's Brian where's the birthday
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
the Backstreet Boys plan to release a
new single this summer as you saw the
guys are all family men now and I
noticed most of their fans bought their
boyfriends husbands even their parents
to the show it's one of those things you
know you I wasn't a huge fan growing up
because they're a little younger but
when I'm in the audience everybody was
doing the back sorry everybody great you
still doing it that's wonderful oh yeah
Thank You Vlad thank you vampy 'pls
still show up to see them thanks a lot